When you type your name into Google,
a lot of articles come up about your hairstyle.
I'm really glad that's the autofill
and not like Cole Sprouse feet or something disgusting.
Yeah, hair, that's a relief.
Right, that seems pretty low key in 2021.
I'm glad it's about hair.
Yes, exactly.
You really are an interesting person
with interesting opinions.
So I did want to get your take
on some current pop culture trends, are you in?
Okay, yeah, let's go.
Okay, 'cause we're calling it the Cole Poll.
(light music)
(audience softly cheering)
Okay, while Riverdale has been on hiatus,
it seems like everyone's been binging Netflix's Bridgerton.
What do you think, Cole?
I think those are some of the most beautiful actors
I've ever seen in my life.
I can't say I've watched too much of it
but I've heard a lot about the sex scenes,
which seem to be incredible according to TikTok.
But I haven't seen it.
Though I do love the fashion and the hairstyling.
They're, it's so good, and they just came on the show
and it was dynamic to speak to them
because they are waking everybody up. (softly laughs)
Okay, next I just read an article
on Buzzfeed about pandemic tattoos.
Should we all be passing the time right now
by gettin' some ink, what do ya think?
Well, you know, my generation has been doing
stick-and-pokes inside their house
for like the last 10 years.
I have a feeling everyone's
gonna walk away with a tattoo.
I just don't know if the origin story
sounds too good, you know?
Like, "Yeah, I got this 'cause
"I was super bored, and I wanted
"to stick and poke my friends during one
"of the biggest pandemics in global history."
You know, I just don't think it really,
it's not a good origin story.
My dad is covered in tattoos and he had a little saying,
which I take with me which is, "You should think
"about a tattoo for nine months 'cause that's the time
"it takes to have a child and that's a lifelong decision."
Oh, that's really profound and perfect.
I had a stick-and-poke tattoo once by Billie Joe,
the lead singer of Green Day and-
That's way cooler of an origin story.
It disappeared though, which is fine.
Right, well, next time he's really got
to use the hammer and chisel.
Totally, it seemed like a fun idea at the time
but then when it disappeared, I was like, and there goes.
Sex and the City is coming back with an HBO Max reboot.
But without the Samantha character,
Cole, is it still really Sex and the City?
Which one is Samantha? (both loudly laughing)
I've never, okay, I watched Sex and the City a little bit.
She's the one standing up in the back.
Oh.
Kim Cattrall,
She was in Mannequin, she's like everything,
I was watching Sex and the City while I was doing a TV show,
and it, she affected my performance a lot.
Like everything I started doing sounded like Samantha.
I'll do the Samantha for you.
Okay, hold on.
Yes, please.
So here would be a Samantha.
Sex and the City is getting a reboot.
(static drowns out Cole)
Yes, and now it's like-
So she's not gonna be on it.
She's not gonna be on it and again,
everything she said was about sex.
It sounds like the cast of Riverdale
when the cameras are not rolling.
Oh, that's fun, makes going to work better.
Yeah, reboots are a tricky thing, you know?
The original shows, when they become successful,
sit within this golden little plate
of nostalgia and when you modernize it and go back to it,
it has the potential to really
disenfranchise the original fan base.
So it's a very, very touchy thing.
I'm asked all the time if Dylan
and I are gonna do a Suite Life reboot
and I go, "No, absolutely not."
Well then I'll skip the next question.
(audience loudly laughing)
All right, chess is everywhere right now,
thanks to The Queen's Gambit, chess fan?
I can't say I'm a chess fan.
I know how to play, but let's be honest,
It's really cool to watch her play it
when it's on a Netflix show.
She makes it look fantastic.
But when was the last time
you actually sat and played chess?
It's not the most exciting game.
And I grew up spoiled with video games
and that's such an interactive medium.
And I can't go from playing a man
surviving the apocalypse to chess.
I'm desensitized now.
It's true, actually, I think it's the video game industry
just surpassed the music industry at $180 billion
of 2020's annual revenue.
So everyone is being desensitized,
Cole, it's happening, it's real.
I do wonder like you're an archeologist.
I mean, man, since the beginning of time,
didn't live in a virtual-reality world.
Do you think we're gonna be okay?
It is intriguing how the entertainment mediums
have evolved over time.
We had audio, then we had visual.
Now we have virtual reality, which truly takes over most
of our senses and we're fully interactive.
I have a feeling and I'm, I don't know,
I'm one of these guys that watched WALL-E
and saw like the big people in the chairs floating
around the humans in space and got really excited.
I'm excited for when I'm 80 years old
and I can just sit in my virtual reality chair
and be riding some unicorn across
like some apocalyptic plane.
And I will, my legs might, my body might be old,
but I get to fully immerse myself
into a virtual world when I'm 80.
I'm excited for video games
when I'm an old man so I can just plug in.
Well, you just-
I wanna enter the Matrix
and I don't wanna realize I'm in the Matrix, you know?
I don't know, you just brought a poetry
and romance to the apocalypse though, so thank you for that.
You're welcome.
Oh, I heard that you had a little crush
on Jennifer Anniston when you were a kid
doing Friends, is that true?
Yeah, yeah, I did, it actually made it quite difficult
to work in front of her, I must admit.
I was a child, I would stammer a lot
and I'd forget my lines, which I feel like I'd maintain
my composure a bit more effectively now,
but it was quite difficult when I was a kid.
And I was teased a little bit by the crew
'cause they saw it and I would just forget
and be looking at her like.
But then the whole world had a crush on Jennifer Aniston.
Well, the whole world has a crush on you, too, Cole.
At this point, I'll take whatever I can get.
Well, I will take this opportunity to finally meet you
as someone I have watched and cheered on along the way.
And really, like watching you become
who you are has just been fascinating
'cause there's so much to you.
Well, thank you so much and thank you
for having me on the show, Drew, I appreciate it.
I couldn't be more grateful, thank you so much.
The pleasure and the honor.
My pleasure,
I can't wait to meet you in person, my dear.
I look so forward to it, perhaps much sooner than later.
And the Riverdale season five premiers
tomorrow night on the CW.
(upbeat music)